you know who gets the my final rose you
tell me our audience oh it's time for
games what news let's just get going it
sounds like the room is richer and
Niantic are indeed working on an
augmented reality game based on Harry
Potter that's still relevant Shazam
in a press release on this site Niantic
have confirmed that their follow-up to
the hugely successful starting small
talk with strangers game Pokemon go will
be Harry Potter Wizards unit there's not
much to go on just yet but Niantic have
said players will quote learn spells
explore their real-world neighborhoods
and cities to discover and flight
legendary beasts and team up with others
to take down powerful enemies I can't
wait to once again be sorted in the
Hufflepuff and get a goddamn we use a
Patronus well I was the other day
Slytherin and my Patronus isn't a de
great thanks just thank the dev also
said they'll be using the new game to
pioneer all new technology and gameplay
mechanics so fingers crossed this one
launches without the server issues that
have plagued Pokemon go if you want to
know the latest on Harry Potter AR keep
tuning in to GameSpot news and we'll
keep you in the loop star wars
battlefront 2 is out next week and we
now know how much the much-maligned loot
crate's are gonna cost as a quick
refresher back when battlefront 2 had
its open beta last month it was
discovered that the new loot crate
system that Awards star cards was a
little unbalanced players were getting
stuff like weapon scopes and buffs to
health purely by chance so
understandably this concerned many as to
how this seemingly paid a win model
would work in the full game dice were
quick to respond explaining that they
were changing the way the loot crate
system worked saying we're working
towards having the most powerful items
in the game only erna believe i ingame
achievements blue crates are indeed a
noble through gameplay but also by
spending the game's virtual currency
called crystals itchy and scratchy money
aka crystals can be bought for
real-world money with the cheapest 500
crystals going for $4.99 and the most
expensive 12,000 pack for $99.99 there
are three flavors of loot crate's
because of course there are with hero
crates running 110 crystals Starfighter
crates for 120 crystals and tripper
crates for 200 crystals if like me you
immediately busted out your calculator
to figure out how many loot boxes a
hundred bucks will get you those prices
amount to sixty trooper crates for 100
bucks
I'm not a fan of the random chance of
loot boxes delivering anything that
isn't a cosmetic so none of this sits
well with me Star Wars Battlefront 2 is
out next week on November 17th but you
can play a 10 hour trial right now if
you're a member of EA access on PC and
Xbox one
just the Xbox one accidentally just come
out okay but people are already talking
about the PS 5 in the Xbox one -
whatever it's gonna be called who knows
yeah probably not one - but we'll say
Ubisoft half however weighed in and said
they don't think we're gonna see the
next generation of consoles for at least
two years in an investor's call Ubisoft
CEO is Guillermo said as Sony launched
PlayStation 4 Pro last year and
Microsoft Xbox one X this year we think
we still have a minimum of two years in
front of us before something new is
coming the UV boss was careful to add
but that's our perception we don't have
any confidential information on that
front oh nice
Jemma went on to say that he's happy
Sony and Microsoft are updating their
platforms with iterative new consoles in
the ps4 Pro and Xbox one X he explained
that is going in the right direction
rather than trying to do accessories or
other things that is going to help the
industry a lot because the games will be
really beautiful on those machines you
and I have disagreed a lot on iterative
consoles
I'm all for them I like the idea of
every you know three years comes out
with a new console that's a little bit
more powerful and I can still play my
old games on oh I think playing old
games is great but I just think there's
a lot of money to keep dropping on what
is almost the same console but if you
don't have to that's why that's why I
like it it's like it's like my iPhone
I've had my iPhone for like four years
now and I don't feel compelled to buy
you know the very next iPhone some
people do and that's fine if anyone have
never buy new phones it's like like
shitty old phones so I think that pretty
much explains could you say like if you
you build your ps4 for like you know six
years and then they're like hey here
comes the ps4 point eight you can buy it
it's like five hundred bucks and no pro
oh oh but it's called the P and I'm
saying the one after the ps4 right you
can buy it and it's gonna play all your
all ps4 games and it's also gonna make
the new ones that come out look even
better that's something that I think is
is definitely something I'd be much more
receptive to I think the thing is people
looking for more of a revamp if they're
dumping hundreds of dollars which is why
I think there's more of an interest in a
brand new console like say the
difference between a ps3
ps4 than just the difference between a
ps4 and a ps4 Pro I think when people
are dropping five six hundred dollars
we're just like looking for a bit more
of a bump and more of a change than an
iteration yeah well I think I'm hoping
for at least when we do eventually get
this new console generation that they're
taking cues especially from Microsoft
with the way they're handling backwards
compatibility this generation that in
the next generation we can still play
the games that you know I've spent a
ridiculous amount of money on on that we
can agree that is everything we've got
for you today do let us know what you
thought about today's stories down in
that comment box and we'll be down for a
chat otherwise we'll give you more news
tomorrow see you then well it's
Wednesday I'm Dan I'm Jeff and I was
asked yesterday about my t-shirt it was
just a t-shirt I don't know what that
was some kind of cool shirt yesterday I
don't know just a black Skippy probably
let us know I don't know what's
happening I'll see nice hmm okay that
one again sure